[Musique]
ben ali
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
envoyer des images de la cérémonie au
cours de laquelle la dépouille de la
juge ruth bader ginsburg a été exposé en
chapelle ardente au capitole c'était cet
avant midi c'était une première
d'ailleurs pour une femme
ce soir en fait on vient d'apprendre le
nom de la personne qui va la remplacer
la cour suprême des états-unis s'agit
d'ennemis qu'on libère est une
catholique pratiquante de 48 ans une
mère de sept enfants
c'est l'un des sujets du carnet mellick
avec karine brémond politologue à
l'école de politique appliquée de
l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir karine bon on va commencer avec
ce sujet on a tellement de sujets de
toute façon on s'attendait il y avait
deux candidates celle ci semble son nom
tous les médias américains confirment
que ça va être annoncé demain
depuis une semaine à madame ginsburg est
décédé vendredi dernier une semaine ça a
été un point tournant dans la campagne
et les républicains tiennent à nommer le
successeur rapidement parce que les
conséquences politiques sont importantes
oui absolument et on se rappelle en 2016
que c'était les républicains qui avaient
empêché le vote sur la nomination que
barack obama avait fait en février après
le décès de scaglia alors le les
républicains disent verts on risque
peut-être de perdre la maison blanche en
avoir alors une fois absolument
entériner la nomination de cette
nouvelle juge parce que on va avoir à ce
moment là une majorité conservatrice
suffisamment forte à la cour suprême
pour que l'héritage conservatoire en
fait l'héritage du parti républicain et
d'une certaine façon puisse durer
pendant des décennies encore un compte
tenu de son âge elle pourrait sceller
l'orientation de logique de la cour avec
les deux autres domination de monsieur
tron pour au moins 40 ans en fait oui
absolument et il faut pas oublier qu'un
autre juge nommé par un président
démocrate monsieur stephen breyer a 82
ans alors
encore une fois là ça risque si dans
notre champ par exemple est réélu en
avance mais ont contraint qu'à ce moment
là on va se retrouver dans une situation
la cour suprême est composée de sept
juges conservateurs et deux juges
progressistes
alors effectivement les nominations plus
récentes sont plutôt jeunes nous grave
kavanagh qui a remplacé le juge scalia
ans la jeune cinquantaine dont on parle
de peut-être trente ans le assurément
avec une domination conservatrice
est ce que selon mme à deux tranchants
pour le plus d'entrain
oui dans la mesure où effectivement il
peut réussir son pari bien sur inferno
mis sept juges leur mais peut-être que
ça va mobiliser les démocrates davantage
aller voter en novembre justement pour
éviter qu'ils en fassent face une autre
nomination c'est d'ailleurs ce que joe
barton prétend par ailleurs que ça va
énergisé les troupes démocrates mais si
on sera évidemment petit et ça ne
peuvent être la transition vers le
prochain sujet au fond ce que craint
donald trump et il le répète depuis
plusieurs jours
c'est dans le fond le caractère
frauduleux illégale de la prochaine
élection du toit fait d'élection 3
novembre
alors il veut avoir des justes qui lui
serait favorable éventuellement dans
l'éventualité d'une décision de la cour
suprême pour des tranchées le l'issue
d'élections
le principal problème avec parfait il ya
plusieurs d'avoir que l'élection soit
frauduleuses
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'indicateurs qui
nous permettent de penser cela en
particulier avec un vote par la poste
qui est quand même assez bien rodé
malgré ce que dans l'autre chambre les
républicains disent et aussi le fait que
c'est habituellement ce n'est pas la
cour suprême des etats-unis qui tranche
lors d'une élection s'il ya des
contestations juridiques ce sont les
cours concernés qu'ils vont le faire
mais ultimement si jamais il y avait
égalité par exemple des grands électeurs
au collège électoral donc 270 à 270 par
exemple évidemment c'est la chambre des
représentants et sénat qui vont trancher
la chambre des représentants tranché ce
moment là entre le choix du président et
le sénat tranché en termes de vice
président à la cour suprême après un
site ne soit pas là il est le fantôme de
2000 évidemment acquis qui plane au
dessus des têtes peut-être parce que
c'est une décision la cour suprême qui
va mettre fin aux records
page 10 mois mais qui va pas
nécessairement tranché directement le
gardien mais il demande somme notre
chance si c'est suffisamment serré si la
cour suprême mais de mon côté
à ce moment là j'ai peut-être plus de
chance cependant de vie je me suis
investie par une voix seulement que la
cour suprême avait tranché en faveur ou
il arrive du recomptage en faveur de en
faveur des républicains
alors si ça devient danger déclare ce
qu'on a vu l'aiguillé des sondages
bouger un peu pour le positionnement des
enjeux parce qu'elle est depuis une
semaine on parle très peu de la pandémie
on parle mais malgré ce qui se passe à
louisville on parle très peu des
tensions raciales le sait la cour
suprême qui prend le dessus est ce que
ça va être ça jusqu'au 3 novembre
d'après vous ça me surprendrait parce
que les événements se succèdent à une
vitesse folle c'est toujours le cas
pendant la campagne électorale
présidentielle maison cette année on est
d'avoir une situation particulière sur
la scène nationale ça bouge un petit peu
c'est peut-être plus la semaine
prochaine pour le sort à dubaï vient de
même encore par à peu près un site sept
à huit points de pourcentage problème
c'est joe boyd on le voit pas beaucoup
on l'entend mais non encore une fois
c'est dans mon job qui mobilise l'espace
médiatique qui mobilise la parole
publique alors inutilement il faudra que
bach haydn prennent un peu plus de place
parce que sinon effectivement l'histoire
sera racontée par dans l'aude jean
ferrando trop en avant qui sera trop
tard parce que dans les sondages
nationaux bail de neuf ans mais dans les
étapes pivot ça se resserre beaucoup les
luttes sont beaucoup plus élevés pour
les sondages et c'est ce qui peut
abriter remuant par quelques milliers de
voix pour l'issue du vote en plus tout à
fait c'est pas au niveau national que ça
se décide c'est dans une dizaine d'états
clé et vous avez raison ça se resserre
depuis quelques jours on entendu les
extraits de trump et de monsieur byden
en réaction des gens se pince pourtant
moi je parle de poser la question est à
peu près un an
et si monsieur tron décidé de ne pas
quitter le pouvoir
et c'était une question presque farfelu
hypothétique mais là vous devez pas vous
en fait des cauchemars voir ce que je
pense il ya même un syndrome
identifiés aux états unis d'inquiétude
relire cette question là paraît-il que j
ai pas de cauchemar parce que en
principe ça n'arrive pas c'est à dire
que je mettais ma maman la constitution
qui force
en fait l'arrivée du nouveau président
au plus tard le 20 janvier à l'idée mais
pour plus tard le nouveau président quel
qu'il soit devient officiellement
président est donc celui qui occupait le
poste avant ne plus cette fonction de
plus ce titre alors formellement il ne
peut plus être président alors est ce
qui est toujours un peu étrange dans
cette affaire c'est qu'on pose la
question à charm comme s'ils avaient le
choix comme si c'est lui qui décide s il
ferait le transfert du pouvoir ou pas et
ça lui donne une occasion pour semer le
doute parce que c'est ça l'objectif
je crois certaines qui pense qui va
faire ça mais ce qu'il veut à tout le
moins c'est rendre cette élection la
plus la plus controversée possible de
semer le doute dans la tête des
électeurs en particulier des siens il le
fait d'ailleurs en disant que bon en
pennsylvanie on avait jeté des bulletins
de vote comme ça et comme par hasard
sept des neuf bulletins rejetés étaient
des votes pour 3 ans sur site a fait
partie de cette façon de faire qui l'a
de miner la crédibilité de l'élection à
venir ou qu'elle vous justement où elle
al'avantage rapport mais le transfert du
pouvoir il aura pas le choix le faire le
synode ailleurs un vote une résolution
unanime à cet égard là même les
républicains ont dit il n'y aura cette
transition il y aura ce transfert si ma
petite chambre devait faire des lectures
monsieur bacon or évidemment ça va
dépendre de l'interprétation qu'il fait
des résultats comme l'intervention qu'il
faisait de la foule présente à sa
dernière
oui investiture alternatif karine
plaimont toujours un plaisir aussi par
la semaine prochaine la semaine de
débats alors on s'en parle certainement
y voir l'impact qui est le meilleur dans
ces débats merci car ils vous plaisir
merci